it's okay uh welcome to the gdps seminar
everyone uh before we introduce our
invited speaker let's go over some rules
and Logistics first of all please mute
yourself during the top on this you have
questions if you have questions you are
welcome to mute and ask otherwise please
use chat room to post your questions so
that we can address them in Q a session
at the end second today's gdpr seminar
is open to external audiences
therefore no classified discussion is
allowed so please watch out finally The
Talk today will be recorded and uploaded
in our YouTube channel that's about it
now let me introduce our speaker today
it is an honor to host Eric the
installer who is a professor of
mathematics at Virginia Tech as well as
a professor in the computational
modeling and data analytics program
he was head of the mathematics
Department from August 2018 till August
2020 I mean 22. which was like like two
months ago previously he was a professor
of computer science at the University of
Illinois at Urbana champion and the
senior research scientist that in
interdisciplinary project Center for
super Computing at ETA eth Zurich he
works on the theory and development of
iterative methods for large linear and
non-linear problems including high
performance Computing implementations
randomizations optimizations inverse
problems and their applications he is a
lastly Fox Prize winner his research is
highly interdisciplinary including
collaborations on the optimal design of
structures and other computational
mechanics problems
tomography and initiative construction
electronic structural computations
photos and synthesis and optimizing
plans for carbon fixations and computer
Graphics his work has been supported by
Major grants from NSF video we NASA
afosl and Cynthia National Labs he has
served as an editor for multiple
journals among others for apply the
numerical mathematics and for science
journal on numerical analysis and he was
the program director of The Siam
activity group on super Computing from
2003 to 2006. he currently serves on the
board of directors of the Computing
research Association today
Eric will talk about chip and robust
adaptive reduced to the models for
non-linear inversion and design which is
a very interesting topic so I'm sure you
will enjoy his talk today and now
without further Ado let me pass the
button to Eric by asking one random
question as usual today's random
question
I got that from some random websites
it's if money were no subject say you
are billionaire now what would you do
today
what would I do I think I would mostly
be doing what I would be doing now so
wow so okay so the money doesn't matter
so you will do whatever you're doing
right now that's awesome you're already
happy person
all right right all right that's the
stage is yours Eric
okay well thank you and I think thank
you for inviting me to present here and
and thank uh you for everybody's kind of
making time to hear this talk and um
I'll be happy to answer questions
um
all right so let me first kind of point
out a whole bunch of collaborators so
the things I'll be talking about some of
it is being built up over quite a few
years and so two graduate students
Munster uh having done a lot of this
work
um and then there's several
collaborators in the shakilmer serpent
version and Chris PD uh being very uh
helped me with various components
including you know tomography the model
reduction so on
the collaborations on especially
topology optimization being with Laos
Molino has been a long-term collaborator
with Sally Zhang and then the sum of the
stochastic components being worked with
Alex Shapiro and it's being supported by
you know a range of
um Brands so
let me give you a quick overview so so
some of the applications of Interest are
um tomography uh as well as
um topology optimization uh emotionally
pde constrained optimization I
highlighted tomography because that's
mostly what I'll be talking about
um so I'll give a quick idea of the you
know what the former model is what so
what's the problem we're solving and why
is it so expensive
um I'll kind of take a quick look at the
the problem in the algebraic sense
because that kind of shows why we can
use these same methods for very
different problems which of course for
us as computational mathematicians is
very interesting
um then I look at parametric model
reduction and randomization to solve
these problems these very expensive
problems more efficiently
um
in this talk the emphasis will be
somewhat on model reduction and then the
randomization to help the model
reduction but we've also used
randomization more directly
um so we look at randomization to
officially compute expense you know
reduce order models so the reduced to
the model is having very effective but
they're still expensive to compute
um and then we look at
because our models are in a high
dimensional parametric space if you look
at stochastic estimates to estimate the
accuracy of the model and then if it's
not good enough right we want to update
them we want to do that efficiently so
then you know I'll talk about I'll
present some results throughout the talk
and then at the end I'll have some you
know discussion some summary and future
work and so you can kind of see a design
on topology optimization that was
actually built you know using
randomization
um
so okay white tomography so this is kind
of a quick slide
um you know if you want to look inside
the body uh by only taking measurements
on the on the outside right that can be
very beneficial
to whatever you want to look at or say
boss right so these are paintings by um
Ryan uh famous Dutch painter and it kind
of shows you you know what people had to
do before with the dudes about it
so it was kind of unpleasant for the
patient
all right so so in diffuse Optical
tomography uh you know tissue is
illuminated by near infrared frequency
modulated light uh right so kind of you
know you send it in from one side or
from both sides and both happen you know
the light kind of travels and then the
result is measured in detectives on the
other side
um so tumors are very different Optical
properties than the surrounding tissue
that is mostly because they mean a lot
of vasculature to grow quickly and so
you get a big contrast and that allows
us to recover images of optical
properties of say the diffusion field in
the absorption field so BX and ux in
this kind of diffusion absorption
equation uh in this talk will only uh
invert for the absorption new
and this problem is still post and it's
typically underdetermined it's in fact
highly data limited so we'll show that
you know so per frequency maybe we take
like a thousand measurements but you're
talking about you know hundreds of
thousands or millions of sounds right so
it's a highly underdetermined problem
and of course it's noisy
um so we solve the tomography problem in
this case but we're kind of I call it
invert for shape because we're looking
for kind of zero one type solution so so
for that reason
so you know that you're looking for
things that have a relatively high
contrast so rather than invert for
absorption per pixel which often leads
to very smoothed out gray levels because
of the regularization it parameterize
the medium and sold for the perimeter so
we have a non-linearly scratched problem
to solve that kind of looks like this
right where MP models you know the map
from sources to detectors with the
median parametrized by A Primitive
Vector T and then the observations that
are made and D is the data Vector I put
the regularization in Brackets because
for the the parameterization we use it
more or less yields regularized
Solutions so we don't need to regularize
on top of it so we'll parameterize D and
mu by expansion in compactly supported
radial basis functions I'll show an
example uh in a minute
and then we mapped it to kind of a
piecewise constant function using an
approximate heavy site function
approximate because we want things to
remain differentiable using parametric
level sets and so the the the the
modeling I'll talk about in this talk
comes from a paper by Agassi Kilmer and
Miller but I should say we recently
proposed a much better kind of
parameterization for these parametric
level sets and we can find this on the
archive
um and then we we solved the
corresponding non-linear Express problem
using a specially designed trust region
method that kind of regularizes the
Gauss Newton search Direction so it
basically recognizes the Jacobian uh
that gives you your you know your
stepwise print Newton steps espresso
and the objective function of Jacobian
require a large number of linear Souls
because there are many sources and many
detectors so just to kind of show you
how this looks like so your
um your expansion in radial basis
functions gives essentially like the
hilly landscape which you can kind of
see if I can get the pointer going
um
all right so you have this hilly
landscape and now you pick a a cut off a
level set and then whatever sticks out
above the level set is essentially
anomaly and whatever is below is is
background right so here you can kind of
see the colors are not so maybe not as
clear as they could have been you can
see several contour lines and so it's
this contour line here basically this
little books here that correspond to the
level set and so that gives you
basically this picture
I'm going to give you an example of a
reconstruction so so this is our initial
condition we use it initial conditions
of this type or for uh almost all our
problems because that kind of you know
now
turn around the movie
um so the first few steps are very slow
so you can kind of see how from Step
optimization steps up to these things
change they change very drastically in
the first few steps and then they
changed very smoothly uh as you reverse
to the solution
then at the end I'll show the original
um true solution that would be kind of
inverting for
so you can kind of see how the perimeter
as the perimeters change kind of the
hilly landscape and therefore the level
set kind of changes and that determines
uh what is sort of inside and outside
the anomaly and you can see that you get
very even though the problem is there
limit you get very sharp kind of balance
which is the purpose here okay so this
is the uh it was kind of a friendly
anomaly in this this case we were
inverty
um
okay so here is the forward problem so
you already saw uh the
diffusion equation so this is basically
this is posting the frequency domain so
Omega here is the frequency modulation
of the light use the absorption D is the
fusion we assume here diffusion is given
and we only invert for absorption
um but in general you would parametrize
both and then solve for the parameter
the discretized form you basically are
looking at this transfer function that
is parametrized by P in in general we
only have a few frequencies so that
period explicitly we won't do model
reduction in frequency space
um so The Columns of B correspond to the
sources then of this you know is your
inverse the inverse of the discretized
pde and then C transpose tells you what
your detectives see and the number of
sources in detectors can be quite large
from hundreds to a you know in the order
of a thousands that means you know
solving a very large number of in
general 3D discretized pde so that makes
it very expensive
um we want to minimize the misfit so the
residual which of course is 10 you know
your computex outputs minus the data and
so that so a function evaluation
basically requires number of sources
times number of frequencies largely
large 3D pdes per step so it's very
expensive for these problems
um using a Newton type method is very
effective and so we'd also like to
approximate the Jacobian and so the
derivative of a respect to parameters is
relatively easy to compute so we use
kind of a posting approach on adjoint
approach so we solve both for kind of
the detectives with the transpose of our
problem or Matrix and for the sources
but so to compute the Jacobi and you
need an extra number of detectors times
number of frequencies solves as well so
the computational course costs are very
large
um
now a quick look at these problems in
the discrete form so you basically see
what you're minimizing here right it's
like a frobenius norm of a blocked by
linear form of a function of a matrix in
this case the inverse
um in the topology optimization case
um we would for example for compliance
minimization you would be minimizing the
trace of this where The Columns of f are
different mode cases and they could be
weighted in terms of which locates you
care about more and so for example Trace
estimates for both of these right are
very effective at estimating
um
at estimating these objective functions
as well as getting derivative so so
there is a lot of commonality in the
methods you can bring to bear on these
problems and other pde uh constraints
and organizational
so so we're looking at bilinear and
queretic forms involving the linear
inverse more generally this could be
some function of the Matrix and again
that can be done very efficiently with
all kinds of thrill of methods and so
okay so the problems we're looking at
are tomography optimization but also
with some Engineers here looking at
certain other quantities of Interest
using
um transport of the sensitivity or
adjoint equations and so on so so
there's a lot of
problems where you can bring this
technology to there
um
but he's very expensive problems we
started to use model reduction I don't
know I think we got some money 2012 or
2013 and so okay so 2015 is our first
paper but of course a lot of other
people have used a model reduction
especially for various optimization
problems not as much although it's
becoming much more for inversion so so
at the time the number of people for
using it for a large given version
wasn't that large
um but in things like optimization and
so on the design operation there's many
many more people you know this is just a
subsection I mean there's a large number
of people involved in this
um our work on randomization that kind
of got started by some discussions with
ldot labor and the paper he published
with Matthias Chung and some other
polymerators
um his work by Fred roosta at UCB we
extended this somewhat by combining
simultaneous random sources with
optimized sources so that was work with
Celine Aslam did as a
uh as an HD student and some other work
which I'll talk about here that she
worked on was using randomizations for
computing reducer remote so they would
do so the models are really uses the
venue for
solving the problems but they're still
kind of quite extensive and in that
sense uh continue to be just model is
still expensive in essence the
randomization kind of help
um
we also use randomization for these
topology optimization or design problems
so that was very good
Shapiro
um
a lot of people have worked on
estimating budding their forms more
directly than one of my other students
or questions even though it's worth
we've seated several things but one of
the things was use randomization and
recycling to estimate what by linear
point this is kind of something we still
need to write up and publish what GP
reading about it in her thesis and uh
okay that last line I think is uh stayed
over from another time anyway
so we have these very expensive problems
to solve and so we want to use model
reduction to do that and since we want
to optimize over the parameters we want
to use parametric model reduction
um so if you you saw this well so here
it is again so here's the transfer
function it corresponds to an equation
in the time domain so my model reduction
uh colleagues and collaborators like
sercom and Chris like to always kind of
go back to the time equation so I'll
describe the Dynamics so we have this
highly uh High dimensional state
so we want to map this to a much lower
dimensional State equation and I'll show
in a moment how you pick the state but
let's say you have a trial space VR
which is low dimensional right so now
you can parametrize X
um as VR times a you know small X
um and then you choose a test space WR
and you apply a picture of the working
condition so basically you want the
residual of this
um differential equation or dynamical
system to be zero and now you can just
multiply through with WR transpose and
you get you know reduced e is WR
transpose e v r reduced a is WR
transpose a of P times V R so the
parametric dependency is preserved uh
and so on and so now your dynamical
system of Dimension R which is generally
is much much smaller than n right uh it
takes the same form so AR is still
parametized by P and you have a
parameterized transfer function which is
really what we care about here because
this is basically what we measured when
we do the thermography
so so the whole trick of course now is
in picking V and W so how do you pick
them so there's nice result by
um Power and BT banner and um your chain
so I think this week to power this video
banner and such as origin
um they basically say like well let's
let this operator SE minus a of P bullet
KSP here
if you pick a set of parameter points in
frequency uh sorry a pick of sample
points and frequency and Sample points
in parameter space and you basically
solve these systems so that the range of
VR so you typically end it with a rank
revealing factorization because this
system tends to be you know uh The
Columns of this makes these tend to be
dependent but if the range of VR
contains the range of
uh
the span of all these vectors and the
range of WR contains domains of the span
of all these vectors then you can prove
or that guarantees that your reduced
model or this transfer function
interpolates the truth transfer function
at all the SP points that you put into
the model the same holes for the
derivative with respect to s in the
derivative with respect to P this of
course is the one we're mostly
interested in if we want to optimize
over
and so one of the things that that is
important to keep in mind here is that
it's really about the spaces that you
spend not so much the basis that you
build although numerical condition
you can think of this as a recipe for
building your reduced model and just to
give you some example
um so here is one so so the signal comes
in from the right and is measured on the
left uh so here's some model
um so these are synthetic problems
um this is a reconstruction using the
full order model so we use 30 sort six
sources and detectors Five interpolition
Points in Perimeter space to build the
reduced model and that just the first
five uh optimization steps so that was
kind of what we did to kind of get
started but it turns out that it works
very well and we all used only one
frequency uh which is kind of then the
zero frequency so the ioma go over
Neutron kind of disappears this gives
you 360 basis vectors
um if you solve the full problem it
requires 1100 large systems to solve
this case so it's 400 by 400 so about
160k unknowns
um
and if you use the reduced model
then okay it takes 1260 steps of 250 by
250. so here we'll basically count large
Souls we're kind of implicitly assuming
that the large soles are large enough
that you use an iterative solver so we
take the number of large-scale solves as
a proxy for cost so here you needed to
do I think 180 so 5 times 36
um for the sources 180 foot detectors to
get 360 bases
so so 360 large solves instead of 113.
so about a factor four
um improvements now
for largest 3D problems with more basis
functions so on this gets more expensive
so we want to still bring the cost of
this further down right and so now the
solution after Computing the reduced
photo model is pretty cheap so it's
really the cost of building Luigi food
so how can we do that right so one idea
that came up was to use randomization to
reduce the global basis costs and I'll
show some uh how we do that in a next
slide but just to kind of guide your
thoughts right so the model reduction is
very effective but the global basis is
too expensive and um
right so we want to so you generate in
general you generate many more vectors
than needed so that is a lot of
unnecessary songs and then you do a rank
revealing factorization that may also be
quite expensive reducing the number of
basis vectors for the final basis to
just you know a modest number
right so these are unnecessary costs and
so you know the extended candidate basis
is low rank and so randomization is a
good way of getting a um a good basis
for the dominance Subspace so to speak
um so we only need the modestly larger
number of sample vectors than the rank
um so a lot about that you can finally
this paper here so this reduces solver
cost and length revealing factorization
costs and there's some other things you
can update it maybe with previous
methods if you think your base is not
good enough in this
variety of things you can do that and it
also helps uh you know with
parallelization
um
so just an example if you look at the
singular values of the candidate basis
that you compute in this kind of
standard recipe you can see that you
have this rapid decay of the singular
values
um and so you know you really only keep
it pretty modest I think in this case we
maybe kept everything above 10 to the
minus 10 but that's already probably
more than you really need but that gives
you like 300 something better but so you
can there's a lot you can throw away and
in fact if we use this randomization and
we look at the canonical angles between
the including the base is the standard
way and competing with this
randomization you can see that those
canonical angles are very very seriously
the cosines right cosine is closest one
so the angles are very small
so that tells you you're getting the
right base
right so so normally you would have you
would this would be your candidate basis
where each CK corresponds to solving for
each frequency for all the source terms
so that's kind of a large number of
souls but then okay if you stack all of
these together and then you could of
course hit this with a random Vector but
of course then you've already built the
basis so you're not going to do that
so so what we do and okay so in each
element of Lambda he would be drawn so
it would be a rather marker distribution
so negative one one with some problem
you know well chosen probability
distribution
um so we don't want to generate the
candidate bases first so you just write
this out in terms of the linear solves
and if you multiply your right hand size
by these random vectors and then you
solve only for though in this case we do
that kind of
you just take a subset or some sample uh
you know B times Lambda K and then solve
for this system
it probably is better to do it for this
whole system and then kind of combine
the multiple Souls you might get away
with fewer uh Lambda vectors in that
case um but that's not what we've done
so
uh so why would this work well so or why
is these bases you know so overcome well
after a few steps as you kind of saw
initially you get very drastic changes
of the medium but then they're very very
smooth
and so in this case we use a finite
difference disabilization so the Delta a
the absorption only happens kind of
shows up on the Matrix on the diagonal
with very small values
so small changes in the absorption image
suggest kind of low rank and slow Norm
changes to the Matrix of these candidate
so in general you can kind of say that
the change in that basis is low rank and
small so that's why you do this for a
set of uh sample perimeter points you
get your vectors look very similar and
um
so the randomization should be very
effective
um there's some other interesting
components right so obviously you can
think of these as a random tangential
interpolation but we are still trying to
approximate the full model in all
directions right so it's not clear but I
mean it's an interesting thing to think
about whether that has some bearing on
this problem
um and so you can analyze a little bit
like if you look at say V1 and V2 so
here we just changed the parameter
Vector
um then so the change in The Matrix is
kind of diagonal with the modest number
of zeros in K modest because you say
your anomaly changes only a little bit
right and the only way you change from
not only to background to background to
a knowledge so this is on the boundary
of that kind of change like a region
that moves a little bit right you have a
modest number of zeros that show up on
the diagonal and so you can show
that's a change in V kind of normalized
by the normal V naught so that would be
the v e compute for uh the a without any
anomalies is bounded by some constant
times H like your mesh width and square
root of K Over K is the number of
non-zero now you shouldn't kind of
interpret this as that it goes to zero
for H goes to zero because K will grow
as well so what you're really looking at
is something like
the ratio maybe between the area or
volume of where you have changes divided
by the total volume but it tends to be a
small constant that kind of explains the
low rank and small Norm changes
so again here's an example if you look
at the global basis we compute
um with randomization and then you look
at say the a inverse B for various
parameters vectors so here again I
ignored the
um the automated frequency so for the
zero frequency you can again see that
the angles
between those faces so this is kind of
what you miss in subsequent parameter
steps
you virtually do not miss anything right
it changes very slowly so this kind of
tells you this is a good idea
um
you see that in the handful singular
values
so here's a reconstruction experiment in
this case this is the true solution
um this is the Reconstruction using the
full order model this is the
Reconstruction using the reduced model
repeated the standard way and this is
the Reconstruction using the reducible
model with a few stochastic sources and
detectors to do the randomization you
can kind of see that things work
um pretty well so here we used four
sample points
um and 12 random sample vectors to do
this reconstruction
here's a 3D reconstruction
relatively small problem I'll show some
larger problems later on and again you
can kind of see this is the true
solution again this we start we tend to
start with the same initial condition
because it works really well
reconstructions using the full order
model
the Reconstruction using the reduced
order model computer kind of the
standard way and the reduce of the model
using the randomization you can
basically see you get extremely built
reconstruction
even in this much cheaper reviews for
the model
and okay here's another one
so here are some um kind of results
right so if you use the full model so
the state you solve it the standard way
you have about 1900 large Souls
uh the reduced model if you set it up in
the standard way has only about 500 so
about a third to a quarter and then a
lot of small systems to solve but you
know who cares about solving at 200 by
200 system
and if you use these stochastic Source
in the text you get another factor three
basically in reduction from this
um so for larger problems uh in the 3D
case uh it gets yet a little better
right so here now we're talking about
effector
15 for the full model
um and we see actually later on there's
yet more tricks we can do that it gets
better and better
um but anyway so it works well and it's
it's cheaper now of course if we make
the reduced model cheaper and cheaper
um we still want to know we're doing the
right thing and this is anyway somewhat
of a problem with these high-dimensional
parametric model reduction it's
difficult to get an error bound so you
can just so what we've been doing so far
and what we did initially is really use
the reduced model blank maybe at the
last step check that your reconstruction
is a good reconstruction but nothing
during the minimization
it's because Computing a deterministic
error boundary
is very expensive right if you had to do
a lot of samples in high dimensional
perimeter space or kind of do some
greedy approach to be very expensive I
should say there's kind of an
alternative approach so we're going to
use stochastic estimates so it's
interesting experience approach by
Elizabeth Chen and collaborators to use
a reduced basis method that does come
then with error estimates
um but so we figured since we're already
using randomization we can obviously use
randomization in this case basically you
know touches and Trace estimates to
estimate the reduced order model oh
sorry to estimate the objective function
so for example you could do this with
one or two solves per step so another
thousand Souls one for every source that
are every detected but just one or two
but that's very cheap
of course it's you know stochastic so
you have to kind of make sure that you
know you know you have to make
sufficiently sure you notice when the
reduced model is off so that's kind of
an interesting
um Problem by itself and and uh I'll
come back to that and then the other
thing of course is if we
if we now notice that to reduce model is
not good enough you have to update the
reduce model now we're using this inside
the trust using method and so there are
these what they call I guess adaptive or
there's another word trust region method
so
if you in controlling the finite number
of steps you can make to reduce your
objective function sufficiently accurate
then the whole trust reason framework
still guarantees convergence and of
course in this case at least in
principle that's trivial because if we
put it into Collision points wherever
our regions model is kind of failing and
at that step we would do the reduced
model we'll do the exact same thing as
the full model because it's
interpolatory
so then our trust region method will
take the same step as if you're using
the full model of course you still think
that's too expensive
um and so if we have to update we also
want a cheap way of updating the reduce
model and so I'll come back to that
foreign
so so how do we update the reduced order
model so
if this is the full model so this looks
something like seed transpose
um a inverse or k is you know s e minus
a of P times
uh B right and then the reduced model
basically looks something like C
transpose
K times
um
now you get the reduced model so that is
V times V transpose k Sorry W transpose
KV inverse times W transform
so anyway
you can you can uh there's a paper on
the archive that lays this up so you can
write this and say well how do we bump
this well you can bounce this by see
transpose times a inverse so this does
not depend at all on the visuals model
times an error that looks like identity
minus
um a projection times the right hand
size B in the forbidius norm and of
course the reduced model plays a role
here so t as a function of frequency and
parameter looks like this so it's k
s e minus a of P times V times the
reduced model inverse times W transpose
and the reduced model inverse again so
that's just W transpose KV angular so
that makes this a projection
so now assume the reduced order model
error is too large at some point at some
point p
right so how could we correct this well
if we think of for now let's say k times
V is QR so QR is a orthogonal basis for
the space of KD
and then your residuals from the kind of
reduced model times uh kind of lifted
back into the full space look like I
minus t times B so you can write this in
in two components it's projection on the
range of Q and if your orthogonal
complement of that
now
the components in the first part already
lie in the space of KV solving for those
components will give you a contribution
in the space V but that you already have
that's already in your reduced model so
that's kind of unnecessary so we will
only need to solve for these components
and then okay we don't want to solve for
all of them so we would like to do as
few solves as possible well
let's look at the SVD of I minus QQ
transpose B and note that you know this
just involves Computing KV and then a
projection on the sources so that's
there's no souls involved and in
principle only a modest number of math
facts and you can cut some Corners there
as well but now let the SVD be given by
U Sigma y transpose
so if you now pick the largest singular
villains and they're corresponding left
singular vectors then you could expand V
with the K inverse say U1 up to us
and because then K times that right
gives you KV you already have and the
set of vectors U1 to U.S which are now
orthogonal to V right because they come
out of this phase
and then you can use the singular values
to basically set up an error bound to
determine how many components you need
to pick right because the new basis I
minus q q tilde QT of 10 plus times B is
bounded by this bank that comes from the
singular values which is bounded by this
residual
so it's kind of residual based combined
with an efficient kind of update and
it's very effective so for the one of
these 2D examples with 32 sources and
detectors
um at the point where our stochastic
estimate says you need to reject and
reduce to the model we have about 11.7
percent relative error and just adding
three additional basis vectors reduces
that relative error by another 95
percent so this is basically the error
over the difference
um detectors
and so you can kind of see this is the
initial error this is what happens so
it's going down by about an order Vector
of 10 or you know from 100 to 5 so 20
um
so and we only
we didn't solve for 32 sources of 32
detectors we solved for three vectors
only right so it's
quite cheap to do this
um and then we do the same thing for 3D
problem
so now let us also have a quick look at
um
uh the importance of that
accuracy check so so here the
um the blue line is the reduced order
model
and the orange line or basically the
misfit as measured by the disease of the
model and the orange line is the true
Misfit you can kind of see initially
they align pretty well but then at some
points the true model doesn't really
improve and the reduced model keeps
going further so so if you stop here you
could be quite misled by the accuracy
that you have achieved in fact the
accuracy is typically set as slightly
larger than the noise level so it's kind
of a discrepancy principle type stopping
criteria and then the green process are
actually our estimates of the objective
function and we'd be basically say like
if the estimate of the objective
function is
some Factor larger than the reduced
model
then the reduced model needs to be
updated
I kind of should say that while this
looks pretty bad in practice the
optimization is quite good so there is
some notion that maybe the derivatives
are much better than the function
evaluation so it's kind of interesting
so the the reconstructions in this case
were still quite good anyway
what we do here is when this when when
uh so these are the interpolation points
so three into placing points are taken
and here one correction is done so you
can kind of see they start to drift
apart at some point not necessarily
immediately our stochastic estimate
tells us that there you know there is
too much of a misfit and then we add an
interpolation point and then you can
kind of see the reduced model and the
you know basically overlaps with the
true
objective function and then of course
the optimization does the right thing
so here we started with three
interpolation points but then the
thought was like well if we can
effectively update the mcstorter model
maybe we should also do fewer into uh
you know use fewer parameter points so
build a much cheaper reduce loader model
further reducing the cost but rely on
updates during the optimization to kind
of fix the reduced model because we can
it turns out we can do that relatively
efficiently right with only a few Souls
so here we used just one interpolation
point to uh set up the reduced model and
of course one installation point is just
the initial condition which means that
is actually something you can compute in
advance so it becomes a purely offline
cost
um so
it's kind of an interesting thing in
terms of the positive element
um of course they drift apart now much
more quickly and so here at step I don't
know 13 or 14 you do a correction and
then they're both for a while here
another correction was done in this case
the correction may not be necessary
because the
um in this case like the
or sorry I need to look at these ones
the
the estimates also of course can
overestimate the error and so you may do
an unnecessary update well you know
it's just too bad but anyway so you can
kind of see we need to do three updates
but the reduced model function
evaluation in the true function version
State relatively
um so here's a 3D test problem for this
case so this is on a 64 cubed mesh so
this is I don't know about 200 000 or
300 000 unknowns in this case we have a
kind of a grid of 31 by 31 sources and
detectors at the top and the bottom or
the left and the right
so we have about a thousand sources
right so think about the full function
evaluation takes a thousand solves times
the number of frequencies I think number
frequencies here might just be one but
still and then for your Newton step when
you updated Jacobian there's another
thousand Souls with the transport
we use 27 of these compactly supported
radio basis functions it gives you 135
parameters so the parameter space is
relatively large and then in this case
basically to tax the reduced model
the the noise is quite low so General
the noise for these problems should
really be order one percent but this
allows us to kind of get better
reconstructions and then basically we
can see better how well the reduced
model is doing
um so here are the reconstructions using
the Florida model
if we use three parameters
uh sample points and no updates
we also know that you can basically see
in the reconstructions you don't
actually see too many differences which
is kind of like I said is an interesting
thing that even though the reduced model
itself is off it seems to drive the
optimization still in a very good
direction
and these are these residual updates
with only one sample point which is very
very cheap and it works still very well
um some costs now since everything is
now stochastic we did a fair I forget
how many but maybe we did this like a
hundred times and then looked at the
median cost of the solves and then here
are also percentiles of the number of
iterations
so the full order model took 23 000
large uh linear solves and if you didn't
do the first
step because let's say you consider
Computing that for the uh initial guess
already right it goes down a little bit
um three interpolation points goes down
to about five thousand if you think
about the only the additional ones that
need to be computed it's only about
three thousand so we're already getting
huge improvements the one point so only
the initial guess if you count that
initial guess right you're doing about
um you know a factor
10 better but if you actually take into
account that you could compute that
reduced model offline in this case and
just do updates then on average right
you go from 63 functioning a large
linear solves to versus 23 000. so you
have an enormous Improvement
in the cost question the Improvement
versus doing the reduced model the
standard way is not not as large right
but still about a factor hundred so very
impressive
um improvements
all right so some conclusions in future
work
um so okay so model reduction is very
effective for this problem and we can
reduce the cost of This Global basis
computation further by randomization
um by doing it very cheap and relying
more on the updates during the
optimization because it turns out that
we can do those quite efficiently
um and there's some further things we
could look at using the angles between
the spaces that kind of are generated so
this is kind of an idea that still has
to be
um kind of you know applied the
stochastic test is cheap and allows
updating the ROM
of course now we did the stochastic test
in this case was done just by one soul
of course you can ask if that is always
accurate enough
um and so one of the things we're very
interested in so this is kind of future
work
is how to how many estimates would be
necessary and you can use a prior sorry
a posteriorly evaluations to get Delta
probabilistically accurate estimates for
the gradient and the objective functions
because that would
um allow us to develop a trust region
method so so there's some work this
would be slightly different but there's
some work by Chen nikoli and some other
people using
um stochastic methods
um that would converge with high
probability so that of course is really
what you want and this should be you
know at an extra cost because you need
to do some more samples
um so that's kind of something we're
kind of working on and you can find the
first uh attempt at that in Drayton
Monster's thesis
um
there's several more possibilities for
efficient approaches uh basically you
know getting a small ROM but maybe a
little bit better than just based on the
initial guess
um
and then the other thing is you know
many problems have this similar
algebraic structure and so we want to
apply these ideas to a lot of different
problems as well
and uh that's it thank you
well thank you so much for the wonderful
talk Eric it was very interesting and
very informative
um thank you so much let's have a q a
session uh if you have any questions
uh you're welcome to unmute yourself and
ask questions or you can put your
question on the chat room so that I can
facilitate later so I don't see any
questions in the chat so let me start
with a question
um very good very good uh Eric if you go
back to the the previous slide where you
showed the summary or the conclusion
so you know stochastic test and one of
the bullet points is the third one the
major bullet point stochastic test is
cheap and a large obtaining one and have
you done any the performance comparison
between you know the usual way of
updating the ROM and also you know the
stochastic way of updating the wrong
those you know which one is
um is faster and and any numerical
performance comparison have you done
well so the standard way of updating the
Roman is interpolatory mode would
basically be kind of the cost of one
full function evaluation right so they
would be solving for all sources and
detectors and then you add those uh all
those directions to your uh model
reduction bases and we do a rank
reviewing factorization so
um
so so the randomization would reduce
that number of solves kind of
drastically so that that you can kind of
see
from an example so this would be kind of
the same
type of reduction of cost is for
building the initial reduced model so I
had some numbers
here
yeah one requires a full linear solve
and the other one does not so
um so it was kind of okay yeah yeah so
that's the then the stochastic estimate
in this at this point we just do one
large-scale Soul so it's basically do a
trace estimate for
um
it will Hutchison Trace estimated for
this Matrix right right
so that requires one soul
um
what do we do too do we do it from the
left side as well okay I have to so one
or two Souls I think just one and so
again that's very cheap but of course
it's not you can look at these um
where we do the correction
um that those estimates are not always
that good right so you can kind of see
here for example while the difference is
small but the estimate for
uh for the diff you know is quite off so
so these estimates are not that good and
so here we just went for
efficiency so we just do one solve in
practice you would probably do a few
more right and that's where kind of
um and so if we apply kind of this
Theory uh that I outlined
for these uh you know probabilistically
accurate so you actually need quite a
few solves and then it gets a lot less
uh good but we think at the same time
like maybe this like if you use the this
is some something to be based on like
concentration inequalities and those are
very pessimistic right so so you know it
may tell you all you need to really do
10 or 12 solves to all of these for
these Trace estimators to get enough
accuracy and but in practice that is
overkill so the interesting question is
to strike a balance there so one is
probably less than you would do but it
works at least for all our problems
right it did find
uh when they drifted apart it did notice
that
um
but yeah so so coming coming up with
both you know stochastically speaking a
robust method that guarantees
conversions with high probability but is
you know as efficient as this that's
kind of a
yeah that's an interesting new thing to
work on right right right all right
sounds good
um I I don't know if I'm allowed
my next question is um you know you kind
of took a balanced truncations types of
video student model here and your
governing equation is linear
um I see and
there are many other types of the
original model like such as projects I
mean the Pod base to reduce that and
also there are quite of work on
extending this reduced model to from
linear to non-linear uh problems as well
so at how do you you know envision
you know extending this you know
framework
of to the reduced model feature well
which is available for the nonlinear
problems and also further uh you know
extending that to the nonlinear
inversion problem
or the topology optimization or design
optimization
yeah
so for so here we use interpolatory
model reduction which of course is very
good for because we're doing parametric
inversion so like I said it has this
nice advantage
that if at some point the model is not
accurate enough then you add an
interpolation point at that parameter
the reduced model at that point will
take the exact will give you the exact
same step as the full model would right
yeah
this this is kind of very nice
um now for for to Ponzi optimization
there isn't like a similar kind of
interpretation of an underlying
dynamical system you're not looking at a
transfer function so I think pod there
would be the more obvious way to do the
reduced model I think that's kind of
what you uh have done
um
EOD
so it's kind of important that
of course your
um your modeling the map from sources to
the textures but
as a non-linear function of the
parameters
actually the PD is linear but the map
from parameters to P to the kind of the
algorithm that is not playing
um so
correct yeah so it's a good question how
other reduced models would do and how
you would bring in the parametric
dependence right so
yeah I guess if we would do pod we
probably would again take some number of
parameter sample points
um then solve maybe for some number of
you know Source detector Maps kind of
added to the bases
how that would compare yeah we haven't
tried
um to some degree because it looks like
the
interpolatory model reduction works very
well for this problem but like you said
for other problems yeah that's a
different question
um if we would do this for non-linear
problems or nonlinear opinions then you
would probably do something like dime or
empirical insulation
um methods
to kind of do that
um we've done some experiments in fact
you saw a siphon structural's name
in the list so she worked on that this
is some time ago
um it was difficult to get it to work
really well for some nonlinear
so
um
yeah so I I my real honest answer would
be I don't know if you had a non-linear
pde probably depends on how non-linear
the pde is
um you know how well it would work or
not yeah yeah sounds good okay thank you
thank you Eric
um is there any other questions from
audience
um I guess we have a shy group today
all right well
um
if not and so let's oh
okay so if not let's thank our speaker
today um thank you so much Eric for the
wonderful talk uh it was very um uh
informal and instructive and I I enjoyed
it a lot so um thank you so much and
starting from today I I hope you will um
have more collaborations uh from
Lawrence Livermore site as well uh that
was guitar and ultimate intention of
this seminar Series so
so all right thank you thank you Henry
yeah well thank you thank you everybody
for who followed the talk um it was my
pleasure and yeah I I definitely think
um you know we'll talk more at yongsu
about some collaborations because we
have great great overlap of Interest
since yeah yeah of course yeah I will I
will send them on a separate email to
you well
um let me stop the recording